s
contres, on leur émet. Voici
comment cela a fonctionné.
- Bonjour ! Comment allez-vous?
- Très bien.
- Je m'excuse de vous déranger
en plein déjeuner. Est-ce que ça
s'est bien passé le passeport
vaccinal?
- J'ai testé mon passeport.
Je n'ai pas l'application,
je n'ai jamais mis d'application
de mon téléphone, je n'ai aucune
idée de comment ça marche.
- Ça a été long.
- Fait que je les sauvé en PDF
puis tout va très bien.
- Cette exigence, pour vous,
elle n'est pas exagérée...
de demander le passeport
par le restaurant?
-Ah! non. Bien c'est ça ou les
restaurants ferment. Je veux
dire, à quelque part on fait
nos choix puis je pense que pour
les commerçants c'est le fun
qu'ils puissent rester ouvert.
Ils en ont mangé toute une année
dernière, on va leur donner un
"break".
- Alors, le passeport vaccinal
ça n'a pas été difficile
ce matin?
- Super, ça a super bien été.
Ça va faire parti de notre
quotidien maintenant, puis si ça
peut aider à sauver des vies,
à désengorger des hôpitaux,
je ne vois pas ce qu'on
pourrait... je ne vois pas
pourquoi on ne pourrait pas
l'avoir.
- Donc pour vous ce n'est pas
une entrave la liberté, parce
qu'il est déjà pas vacciné que
ne pourront plus rentrer ici.
- Non, ce n'est aucunement
une entrave la liberté,
au contraire. C'est pour une
liberté à soi-même et à tout
le monde.
- Bonjour Monsieur, ça va bien?
je m'excuse de vous déranger en
plein repas. Le passeport
vaccinal, est-ce que vous l'avez
présenté, ça a été compliqué?
- Oui, je l'ai présenté, ça n'a
pas été compliqué, non.
- Ça a pris combien de temps
quand vous êtes entrés, deux
secondes?
- Hmmm... je dirais moins d'une
minute, oui.
- Bon.
- Moins de deux minutes de
présenter la caissière et elle
m'a dit, oui c'est correct.
- Très bien, bien bon appétit.
- Merci Monsieur Roy.
- Bonjour tout le monde. Je fais
un reportage, Patrice Roy,
Radio-Canada sur le passeport
On s'en va étudier.
- C'est bien de demander cela?
- Ça aide les gens à se faire
vacciner. Je suis pour ça.
- Avez-vous des amis non
vaccinés?
- Non.
- En étant étudiant, je pense
qu'on a tous compris que c'était
- Ça a été dur d'être seul chez
soi.
- C'est la première fois qu'on
retourne en présence et on
remarque immédiatement la
différence à quel point c'est
important.
- Oui. Je sais pas comment vous
avez fait.
- Ce n'était pas facile.
- Vous êtes en quoi?
- Baccalauréat en
administration.
- On est dans le même programme.
- Bravo. Bonne journée.
- Bonjour tout le monde. Je fais
un reportage, Patrice Roy,
Radio-Canada sur le passeport
vaccinal. Madame a levé la main,
j'y vais.
(rires)
C'est comme a l'école.
Bonjour, désolé de vous
déranger. Mon Dieu, ça a l'air
bon non plus.
- Ce n'est pas un bon exemple
parce que nous sommes français.
De Paris. Et on trouve un petit
peu curieux. Nous chez nous nous
avons deux passeports déjà. Un
français et européen. Et chez
vous c'est ni l'un ni l'autre.
Alors troisième passeport.
- Acceptez-vous passeport
français?
- Mais le QR code n'est pas
valable.
- Ne passe pas avec votre
système de lecture.
- Mais c'est quand même une
preuve de double vaccination.
- Ce n'est pas compliqué.
- Ce n'est pas compliqué du
tout, on a notre téléphone, on
peut avoir un papier si on veut.
Non, ce n'est pas compliqué.
- Est-ce qu'il y a eu des
récalcitrants, ou pas du tout?
- Je n'ai pas eu de
récalcitrants, moi aujourd'hui.
Je suis là depuis 11h30 il n'y a
pas de récalcitrants.
- Il y a beaucoup de monde.
- Quand même, la terrasse est
quasiment pleine, tout le monde
là. Des fois non pas exactement
le petit accès code maison la
photo.
- Testons le mien, je ne suis
pas allé encore au resto
aujourd'hui.
- VaxiCode, ça va être le vôtre,
appuyer dessus, votre nom, vous
l'avez ici, moi je prends la
vérification ici à côté, je
l'ouvre comme ça... voilà.
Patrice Roy certifié par le
gouvernement du Québec. En vert.
- Donc ça a pris exactement
28 secondes, même pas.
- Même moins, je dirais.
- Merci beaucoup, bonne suite.
- Bonne fin de journée, bye-bye.